now what I've got in red is all of the
sort of intermediary steps as you go
along my way to work out what the real
expansions are what's sine of alpha
comes with off
what's cause alpha cos beta all of this
is to get there okay by the way if
you're struggling with just finding that
angle in the corner bpq okay probably
the most direct way this is alphas here
down the corner by alternate angles
right alternate angles in here this is
in there you see it right so you've got
an alpha right yeah that's 90 minus
alpha because the whole angle is 90 and
since this other angle is 90 90 minus
alpha mining the other thing is gonna be
alpha to actually make it a 180 Trident
okay all right now when we have the
question what is sine alpha plus beta
okay
you now have to think about a big
triangle here alpha plus beta is this
whole angle okay and sine is opposite
over hypotenuse right so it's this side
PB on the hypotenuse which is one so
over 1 means nothing so if I can just
find out what PB is then that's in okay
so all of the working you were doing was
to find out this part here the tops part
of PB and the bottom part which is
equivalent here because you got a
rectangle okay
so here's your result for sign up
sweetie Kevin got there okay if you're a
few questions behind drugged down now so
you know where you're headed
okay whether you actually get it right
it's going to be all right this way
first sine alpha cos beta plus cos alpha
sine beta okay it doesn't matter what
water you write it in on whether you
switch these around or whatever by
convention we tend to order it by angle
okay so you see I have my alphas first
there might be a second okay when you're
looking at cos same deal right same
triangle except it's a different side I
want this one down here OB that's the
adjacent side to angle alpha plus beta
okay so to work it out I don't add two
sides I'm going to take a difference I
know what this long side is and I worked
out what this little pot is so I'm going
to subtract
this from that okay so my expansion he
is cos alpha cos beta minus sine alpha
sine beta okay so you can see what the
difference is sine is the one that's
mixed up okay it's mixed up cause in the
same cause pause sine sine which ones
first causes first because it's the COS
identity okay so I apologize these are
really hard to remember they look really
similar okay and we're gonna start using
them and so you want to know which ones
wish so I recommend you write it down on
something nice big color piece where I
put it somewhere
did you look frequently like on the back
of all you know Bobby's door or on the
window mirror or something like that
much so that you can learn to remember
these okay see you next week